my favorite framework for starting a
business is the ponds Lakes Ocean
strategy and so what that means is
rather than trying to go after the ocean
and try and sell to every single person
you want to focus on the smallest Pond
you possibly can of this little Pond I
will be king and once you get really
good at that pond you're like you know
what these fish are a lot like the lake
that's down the street now there's
better more skilled fishermen that are
in that pond and the fish that you're
fishing for there are more varied
because it's bigger but you're like you
know what there's a couple other fish
there that I think I could take on and
you might be able to expand to it and
then finally once you've conquered the
Lakes at some point you're like I am
King of the lake and you can expand to
the ocean but the key is that you have
to start small at the pond to learn how
to fish to begin with you have to learn
how to bait the hook you have to learn
how to attract one single type of fish
learn how the fishing game works in
general and then you keep leveling up
and business works the same way